tja so schnell kann's gehen 18 jahre und
zack auf einmal muss eine veränderung
her
ich bin heute in berlin um einfach mal
danke zu sagen danke merkel
[Musik]
ich bin es mal wieder da ist die freude
groß die freude ist wichtig ich will
doch heute einfach mal danke sagen danke
also jetzt nicht ihnen sind siegen ein
alles gut ist geht es geht um es geht um
frau merkel einfach mal danke merkel für
18 tolle jahre
okay wenn man die gesamtleistung sieht
dann darf man auch schon mal ein lob
wort des lobes ausdrücken ja wie sieht
das aus ruhig mal jetzt auch mal richtig
schön loben nicht immer so ja so ein
bisschen und da gab's ich will einfach
mal meinen eingeladen ist so super das
ist ein toller kerl irgendwie neige
nicht zu emotionalen übertreibungen gut
das habe ich auch schon gemerkt haben
dann bin ich wieder als gut
jetzt ist der merkel zug abgefahren ist
freuen sie sich denn darauf dass die cdu
jetzt wieder ein bisschen asozial
es ist doch so oder so gut danke angela
für 18 jahre treue leitung der partei
neuer leitung der führung für kleidung
klingt vielleicht auch gerade das
absicht war das ein fränkisches christi
ein beschränktes was hattest du genau
was ist das und hat es den hd sd und
buchstaben
wo waren sie als sie die nachricht von
angela merkels rückzug erfahren haben
das weiß ich gar nicht mehr ich meine es
ist eine relativ wichtige nachricht aber
ich weiß sie hat mich nicht so
erschüttert dass ich mein situatives
irgendwo seien völlig eingebrannt hätte
bitte bitte ich war in der
kreisgeschäftsstelle der cdu lahn dill
ich hatte zufälligerweise am tag zuvor
nach der wahlniederlage in hessen dem
dortigen lokalredakteur der wirt
zeitungen gesagt ich würde der kanzlerin
empfehlen den parteivorsitz
niederzulegen und das kam mir dann am
nächsten tag schwacher motor dann in der
tageszeitung groß bringt das heißt das
richtig verstanden sie sind letztendlich
verantwortlich dafür sie haben angela
merkel gemobbt und sie ist dann zurück
betrieb interessant dass wir jetzt
denjenigen gefunden haben hier der dafür
verantwortlich ist
frau nahles was gibt's nur noch eine
wichtige frau in der politik und kramp
karrenbauer was möchten sie angela
merkel gerne sagen ich bin jetzt mal
angela merkel
sie haben für sehr viel kontinuität und
stabilität gesorgt dankeschön
es war auch natürlich durch glückliche
umstände begleitet dass deutschland eine
gute ökonomie hatte in der zeit wieder
ich jetzt noch mal trösten gerne schöne
ist nämlich einfach meinen arm nehmen
ich bin ja ein geländer
frank lamers coach
eine schöne zeit
ich muss gehen
[Musik]